stay like this where you see so much
growth and so much changed constantly
having a limited government apparatus on
top of that and a robust private sector
has been really good for us hi I'm
Alexis Garcia with Reason TV and joining
me is Erica greeter she's the senior
editor at Texas Monthly Magazine and
also author of the book big hot cheap
and right what America can learn from
the strange genius of Texas so Erica
we've heard a lot of kind of boasting
about this big Texas miracle about the
economy and jobs is the swagger deserved
it's all totally true on the economy
side at least it's been sort of a
ridiculous thing to cover as a
journalist because for the past 1012
years pretty much every economic metric
you would look at is better than you see
in the country as a whole better than
you see in most states good for Texas
and also pretty broad-based it's not
just growth for the 1% it's growth for
the middle class the working class in
most industry sectors it's consistent
it's been going on for a long time so
yeah we're doing really well known I
asked that because you know in 2012 when
Rick Perry kind of stepped into the
national spotlight with his presidential
run you had a lot of people like Paul
Krugman come out and try to really
discount the fact that this was actually
happening that this it was too good to
be true yeah it was a I think it was
pretty crazy pretty intense part of why
I wrote the book was just like the
amount of bad information going out
about this it was partly political I
think because Perry's a Republican and
it's a Republican state it's the biggest
Republican state in the country it's the
most important public and state in the
country and maybe partly was because
people have this feeling about Texas
like it can't possibly be doing that
well it's this sort of belligerent state
you know not that smart of a state or
whatever their conceptions are but the
the critique of it I was really
surprised by especially a time when the
country was not doing that well I mean I
would think you at least stopped to
check the numbers first rather than try
to attack them but maybe not you looked
at unemployment you looked at the net
jobs created and it wasn't all because
you know they think they're trying to
tribute that to oil but that wasn't the
case what do you really attribute the
flourishing economy to well there were a
couple of things they would people would
say about I mean oil is one is they all
it's oil jobs which is okay there was
growth in oil and gas and
ten years it's an important part of
state GDP has been for a while it really
drives GDP though rather than employment
it's capital intensive and they'd say
role minimum wage and mik jobs which I
kind of didn't like first of all because
I mean who are we to say what a Mik job
is or what a good job is or not but also
they weren't just low wage jobs you
could see jobs in every income quartile
and the data was all good it didn't come
from Rick Perry it came from the Dallas
Fed so I think the states always had a
focus on business historically not just
the current leaders but the leaders of
the past and it's a small state model
and so that means you need a pretty
robust private sector and need a lot of
industry and there have been times when
the state has not done a while like
during the 80s when Texas economy really
collapsed I think that made the state
more sensitive to the need for economic
diversification and we've seen that
happen since the 80s so now you have an
economy that's not so much driven by
resources as it once was free market
people look at Texas as an example but
it's not as free market as you would
think it is it's not totally free I mean
I think that mercado's does ranking and
post about 24th 25th for regulatory
freedom I think that it there certainly
is a tendency in the state like if you
are being over regulated and you go to I
J or you go to the legislature and you
ask for less regulation and you have K
Sport you can often get that done unless
there's some other lobby against you or
there's some pressing need we've heard a
lot of talk from Democrats and from
President Obama themselves saying that
their major goal is to turn Texas blue
do you see that happening and no not
this year for sure maybe in 2018 they
always talk about in terms of
demographics the states getting younger
it's a going to be I think majority
Hispanic in the next few years it's
already majority minority quote-unquote
it's getting more urbanized it's getting
more educated so you're starting to see
a different kind of constituency in the
big cities but so far no we're not
seeing Democrats put out the candidates
or the campaigns or really the message
the Republicans aren't either which is
kinda interesting there's a couple good
ones coming out but given how well the
state has done I've been surprised by
how the state role can party in this law
set of primaries is focused on issues
that nobody cares about like the 17th
amendment
or you know further marginal abortion
restrictions or further gun laws and I
think those are you know interesting
policy debates but really not the key
issues in a state growing this much and
that's this big I will get Texas and you
know this is a state that gave us Ron
Paul gave us Ross Perot do you see any
more libertarian independent type
politician here that could break out on
the national level well this is an
interesting question so I think that a
lot of Texas Republicans a lot of Texans
in general are sort of quasi libertarian
or tacitly libertarian because of the
issues they prioritize right so even
someone like Perry he's a conservative
he's a fiscal conservative social
conservative but if you think about the
course of his administration and it's
been more than decade um he's really put
fiscal issues first he hasn't really
advanced social issues and I think that
the social conservative movement is just
kind of intrinsically at odds with the
libertarian side of the party but if
those issues aren't being advanced from
social conservative side then you don't
see attention become so manifest you
don't see the fact that they want to
regulate virtually regulate people's
private lives in tension with the
libertarian ethos that more often has
sway but none of the frame it that way I
mean Ron Paul does but most of the
others just frame it as conservative
conservative conservative not even
Republican at this point just
conservative so I'm not sure that that
this time around that causes being well
advanced what has been the role of the
Christian Right here and is it really
indicative of how most Texans are I
think it's a really good question I
think that historically the religious
right as better the religious community
in general has been one of those
institutions that has helped supplement
a very small government and you see that
back in the Frontier Days that you would
have preachers on the Methodists and
Baptists circuit come to town and sort
of give some sermons but also do a
little bit of ad hoc jurisprudence and
you know even start talking about the
need for education so I think that's
that's part of why they have a role in
the state is that they have a history of
being involved in public life but we
haven't seen them generally have power
at the state level and I don't think
most Texans really really want that or
think in those terms and this time
around we've seen a bit of a explicitly
religious
resurgence I mean right now we're going
to go to some run offs the candidate
leading Lieutenant Governor primary is
Smitty who's been saying I'm a Christian
first a conservative second and he's he
didn't win the primary but he's leading
going to the runoff and I was surprised
by that I don't think that is where the
mainstream of the state is or even the
mainstream Republican Party but you know
you get a low turnout election and do
you think that's an odd that towards the
Tea Party though that typically tends to
be a little bit more active and turnout
to them well they certainly I'm not sure
if we even say the Tea Party or the
religious right or the far right or what
we say these days because it was
certainly a conservative subset of the
Republican Party that turned out in
primary in big numbers but you know
they're all pretty conservative in their
public and primary so which part was
really activated was the Tea Party or
the religious right or the church groups
seems like more of the latter the tea
party though I think is a movement that
has the divide between its libertarian
side and its Christian conservative side
which i think is not a divide that
became manifest with somebody like Ted
Cruz who I think is closer to the
libertarian side of that tendency then
the Christian conservative side but I
guess we'll see the tension become an
aura ballif if this continues Erika
thank you so much for joining us today
of course thank you for reason TV I'm
Alexis Garcia
[Music]